traversal district attorney george
gascon getting some support from a
convicted killer take a look
at this prisoner bragging about how the
new rules could set him free
it's monday night right here in a new
folsom seat facility
right here with marcelli some white
lightning
it's a little cup boom celebrating us
going home on this gaskin direct
oh thank you george gaskin here's an
interview that
judge jeanine did with a mother slamming
that same d.a after her son's killer
was granted parole last month no other
family should have to sit there and go
through with me and my family did i
should not have to fight this heart
for the justice that had already been
given to my son
it should not be like this goscoan
doesn't care
so heartbreaking janine um these
families and i spoke to one of them too
they feel like justice was done and now
it's being undone
yeah what's happening in california and
what we're going to see happen around
the country
with these new progressive das as they
call themselves
these are individuals who are not about
crime and punishment and deterrent
they're about forgiveness and this guy
gascone in particular
where the dea has a role to play at a
parole hearing
the mother went to the parole hearing
the d.a was nowhere to be found
they said to her here's the file she
didn't even know she was supposed to
speak
and of course her son who was stabbed
and beaten to death by 14 to 20 people
who was a young teenage boy he then
his murderer got 11 to 25 years he's
celebrating there because he's going to
get out because george gascon
is now not going to any of these parole
board hearings and
on his own he's looking to set back or
review
sentences that he thinks are too harsh
now last i heard as a judge
when i do a sentence it's not up to the
d.a to decide if it's too harsh
but this guy has gotten tremendous
pushback from within his own office
and we're staying on this story this
weekend yeah juan how you know he says
he wants to let people out and live
their lives if they're very
young when they're caught um with these
in these cases heinous crimes um
you know he wants to end tough on crime
you know
what what's the outcome of that what
does it do to the communities and these
people who
were victimized nobody wants any
murders let loose i can say that no
matter which community you go in
but i will say america has the largest
number of incarcerated people in the
world
and we have a lot of people incarcerated
for non-violent crimes that's why
criminal justice reform passed pretty
easily with president trump's support
it was bipartisan i think there's the
potential for more progress there
a lot of people are interested in
criminal justice reform it does not
involve
locating drug crimes not for shooting
someone in the face point blank which
one of these guys is correct
greg um you know what is los angeles
what does california look like under
these kind of laws we've already seen
the deterioration of so many of the
cities
there it's it's reaching the like escape
from l.a point you have a pla
every time the left gains power it's a
pattern
it's they destroy something uh because
they don't actually feel the
consequences of the things they destroy
so the they dissolve processes that are
known to work
in favor of an untested future that
results in the pain and suffering of
others
also maybe uh what's his face what's the
guy's name gaston
gusco maybe he wants to break a record
george yeah he maybe wants to break a
record they've got 300 killings right
now
i guess and it's it's like the first
time they've passed 300 in years
so maybe he wants to get in the record
books right maybe jesse
yeah gascon sounds like a villain in a
disney movie
can we get a two for one when we recall
newsom and gascon that sounds like
a good deal to me i wouldn't be
surprised if he's taking money off the
books
from some of these cartel defense
attorneys
probably funneled it into his campaign
or perhaps his pocket
because no one in their right mind is a
d.a that makes decisions like he does
and is it wrong that i want a taste of
that prison moonshine martha
i don't know about you but there's so
wait how do you get alcohol in prison
but it's water
sugar like oranges or our water sugar
and tomatoes you called me white
lightning and lacrosse in high school
but i want to taste that moonshine i
just don't want to
do the time to have to taste it you
don't want to hang out with those guys
necessarily
thank you very much